[Music]
you save a piece
of each paycheck
to buy a house in your town with a short
white picket fans
you've got the right down payment your
pre-approved display
so you can buy my house
from my cold dead hand
what
[Music]
30 years fix at 2.5 my name will be on
this feed until the day that I die
you
[Music]
they sell it must be some kind of joke
zero inventory within five miles
click renew third like Amber Heard on a
bed I'm spotting right here I hear the
rental markets great around this time of
year so go build your own house
[Music]
wait I don't understand
more cars on the road lesson in the sky
I will oppose on new construction till
the day that I die my property value
might be slightly harm it would change
the neighborhood's character when you
built here this was all Farms senior
homes
[Music]
[Applause]
Congressman Congressman I just want a
house but building here is illegal yeah
it was allowed we could use a voice like
yours keep our house in your plans I
mean you could take bike seats really
yeah
okay okay
[Music]
call me